Загальний дохід
депутата Бундестагу складає -
до вирахування податків – щонайменше
сто шістдесят тисяч євро на рік.
Він складається з декількох компонентів.
"Дієтами" в Німеччині називають
зарплату депутата. Термін походить
від латинського dies, день.
Адже історично зарплата парламентарів
розраховувалася подобово.
Дев'ять тисяч п'ятсот сорок
два євро щомісяця заробляє
депутат Бундестагу наразі.
З 1 липня наступного року
ця сума збільшиться іще
на понад двісті євро.
Із зарплати депутати платять податок на прибуток.
Так звані "дієти"
щорічно індексують відповідно до
покaзників зростання середньої зарплати
по країні. І, тим не менше,
щороку депутати голосують -
чи потрібно наступного року індексувати
свою зарплату. Зокрема,
днями Бундестаг вчергове  схвалив
збільшення виплат. До речі,
рішення ухвалили не одноголосно.
Близько чверті німецьких парламентарів
були проти підвищення власних
зарплат.
Додатково
до основного заробІтку депутат щомісяця
отримує понад чотири тисячі євро
в якості компенсації
на покриття службових витрат -
оренду житла в Берліні, транспорт
і утримання офісу на своїй
виборчій дільниці.
Але і це ще не все:
у депутата є можливість оновити
обладнання офісу на суму
до дванадцяти тисяч євро на рік.
Наприклад, він може купити новий смартфон,
ноутбук чи принтер в офіс.
Однак, такі виплати здійснюються
лише за наявності чеків на покупки.
Компенсації, на відміну
від так званої дієти, не оподатковуються.
А ще депутати мають право
користуватися службовим
автомобілем, а також безкоштовно
їздити в громадському транспорті та
в поїздах Німецької залізниці.
Вони є приблизно у кожного четвертого
депутата Бундестагу.
При цьому більше половини з тих, хто підробляє,
наприклад, адвокатом, радником або лектором,
отримує щомісяця від однієї
до семи тисяч євро.
Парламентарі зобов'язані звітувати про
додаткові зарплати. Однак не повинні
називати точні суми, а лише вказувати,
до якої групи
з десяти можливих належать їхні доходи.
Перша група - від однієї
до тридцяти тисяч євро,
десята - понад чверть мільйона євро.
Втім, у Бундестазі минулого скликання
було лише сім депутатів
з додатковим доходом вище чверті
мільйона євро на місяць.
Багато хто в Німеччині критикує те,
що депутатам дозволено підробляти.
Проблема, вказують експерти,
не в розмірах доходів, а в тому, що у депутатів
може виникнути конфлікт інтересів.